welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down a circle episode 6.
the entry takes us to a brand new
unexplored Galaxy in Star Wars that's
packed with Easter Eggs three times and
lots of things that hint towards the
final two entries I'm thrawny I'm
throwing a throne throne here and if you
enjoy this video please hit the Thumbs
Up Button make sure you subscribe and
let's jump right into it okay so last
week saw what seemed like the world
Between Worlds with Anakin Skywalker
making Ahsoka realize that she needed to
embrace life this was in order to get
her to step away from the dark side and
and the feeling that she had over
Anakin's fall to it as well we saw in
the battle with balen that he tapped
into that directly and focused on it in
order to make her lose her cool Anakin
spoke highly of you this ended with her
going down an angry route and Anakin had
clearly become a weakness for her empty
yeah he's doing a big video breaking
down the lesson behind this but
basically she needed some closure and to
remember that he wasn't the evil man
that he eventually turned into this new
knowledge and acceptance of Life took
her on a transformation similar to
Gandalf where he started Gray I went
into another realm and then came out as
Gandalf the White Anakin also finally
gained the power to save those he loved
from dying which was what Palpatine
tempted him with in the first place now
she's on a different plane of
understanding and finally balanced
likely to properly train Sabine for
what's gonna be coming ahead I know
there's a lot of back and forth over
whether this stuff with Anakin was real
or not but I don't see how a circle
would have survived in the ocean that
long if it wasn't we also had Anakin say
I won't fight you I've heard that before
which I don't think Ahsoka would
actually be aware of to imprint that on
him anyway that should be a fully Co-op
and now we head into Enchanted territory
in the Star Wars Universe a long time
ago
galaxy far far away now we pick up
heading towards the galaxy far far away
which just so happens to be the title of
this entry this of course plays off the
tagline that studied it all with the
opening of every Star Wars film Lucas
did this because it gave a mystical vibe
to the movies and made them feel like
they could have been legends that
happened a long time ago in space who
Yang is someone that used to narrate
Tales like this to children and he
starts them off with a tagline building
off it huge alerts to empty for saying
this might even be a doctor who nod
Judah David Tennant being the Timeless
character that would experience and
create different stories from the places
that he traveled to this episode adds
another place that you've never seen
before in Star Wars so it makes sense
that it would start this way now
watching the subs the lucasfilm logo and
helmets actually begin with Pergo calls
and we start off seeing hyperspace in a
way that we haven't really seen before
with colors whizzing by as they continue
their migration now Ahsoka traveling
inside the pergola at this point makes
me wonder if it's actually lining up
with the Mandalorian season 3. we know
from what the sharoness have said these
shows are happening concurrently with
one another and the purple jump could
line up at the moment in which groku
spotted them grow good already connected
with Ahsoka during the magistrate
episode and him perhaps looking at them
longingly like that was actually him
sensing that she was there now it's a
long journey with huyang and Ahsoka
Reminiscing on the past who Yang is
thousands of years old and he actually
used to make lightsabers for the Jedi to
use He Slipped through countless ages
and met countless Jedis and has certain
insight to how they act and think who
Yang thinks it's impossible for Sabine
to betray them and I feel that's
reflective of his debate than her
despite his seemingly rude comments to
her in episode 2. and when Ahsoka said
there wasn't enough time to prepare
Sabine to make the right choice she's
talking about her not having enough time
to train Sabine into conquering her
fears this is because it was sabine's
fear of losing Ezra that caused her to
join the Buddies to paridia and
basically unleash thrawn now this sort
of book of Boba Fett Mando's season 3 of
soccer at this point and take her out
the episode this is something that we
saw with Mando popping up for two
episodes in Boba Fett and then the
doctor pershing's stuff in Mando season
three in this aspect I feel the stuff
here Works slightly better as we've of
course had thrawn set up as the goal and
no other characters yeah whereas they
were both kind of out the blue and a bit
Breakneck obviously we knew both those
characters but you know what I mean they
weren't really attached or set up in the
show whereas yeah we've spent time with
a lot of these characters know what
their goals are and they've finally
achieved it so it makes sense that they
bring thrawn in at this point now from
here we cut to Sabine in the cell
riffing on not only Morgan in the first
episode but also Princess Leia visited
by Balin she starts complaining about
the view but listen love it's not it's
an uplifty Trip Advisor oh that she does
worry he's gone back on the deal but as
we see throughout they they don't really
though they do have some extra extra
things they add into it that might not
be so good now the Jedi were of course
trained to be mindful of their
attachments so Bala knew he could
manipulate and untrain I like this
however he stays true to his word and
does let her down in the end and finally
they make it out of hyperspace and as we
approach the planet of paridia we get a
couple of interesting tidbits floating
around it is a giant ring and this
resembles the one on the star map from
earlier in the season couple of moments
later we learned that Pergo go inside of
this much like how there was on the map
itself
the ancient home my ancestors the death
of Mary I actually like here that they
give the idea the night sisters and
possibly other magic users we've seen in
Star Wars originate from here we've seen
our Cassat don't necessarily use the
force but they tap into other aspects
and you can see how certain sex and
areas would tap into this too this is
how the night sisters likely operate
before traveling out into other galaxies
creating their temples and then still
studying their Magics as we know peridia
was an old wives tale at circulated
throughout the Jedi Temple so for people
who don't they'd obviously have to come
from this area to spread those tales and
rumors now thrawn's been really well
hidden and none of the characters have
been able to find his exact location or
see his personal data makes me think the
guy hasn't been using space whales he's
been using surf shark VPN the sponsor of
today's video that keeps you in all your
data safe when you're browsing online
search your feelings you know it to be
true and surf shark allows you to switch
your location online while also keeping
your personal data safe from big company
these and cyber criminals now all these
characters going to a different galaxy
it kind of reminds me of what happens
when you switch countries when you're
accessing streaming services little
secret from most guys over in the UK but
we actually have a little little secret
section on the Disney Plus app called
star that's got a range of different TV
shows and movies that you can't get in
the US this happens with all the
streaming services worldwide but
surfshark allows you to access all this
content with just the click of a button
they have over 3 200 servers and this
gives you access to a hundred countries
worldwide use it from the comfort of
your own home or access it when you're
on holiday so you don't miss out on some
of the shows that might not be shown
worldwide that also helps with YouTube
as well and you might not know this but
a couple of weeks ago our Terminator 2
video was blocked everywhere except
America so people in Europe they were
like why why haven't you released this
video to us I was like there's nothing I
can do because the Distributors behind
the film they didn't allow us to
actually show this video outside of
America however what I was telling
people to do was use surf shark and
change her location and hey so they
could now watch the video the VPN also
encrypts your online data and helps to
secure your personal information when
you use free public Wi-Fi that could be
a gold mine for hackers so whenever you
do it I highly recommend that you use
surf shark surf sharks clean web feature
blocks and trackers malware and phishing
attempts which allows you to surf the
web safely right now we also have a deal
where you get an extra three months
completely free and all you have to do
is use my promo code spoilers at
surfshark.deals slash spoilers that
Link's right in the description and also
the pin comment and if for whatever
reason you don't like it surfshark also
offer a 30-day money-back guarantee no
questions asked so there's absolutely no
risk to trying this whole thing out just
go to the link in the pin comment or
description and enter the code spoilers
at checkout at surfshark.deals slash
spoilers that's spoilers at checkout
surfshark.deals slash spoilers thanks
now balen realizes that peridia is a
graveyard due to the piggle skeletons
and stories that he was told there
somewhat speaks to what's going on with
General thrawn and his forces which
we'll talk about later on but this
foreshadows what's to come sensing
Rumblings Sabine gets taken out the cell
and the group will travel down directly
to the planet this is in a ship that
looks like an ornithopter from June with
it also being something that greatly
inspired Lucas's work now the tune I'm
talking about was the David Lynch one
and he was also someone who Lucas
approached when making Return of the
Jedi now they come across night sister
statues like what lined up in the temple
in episode 1. here they also see the
mothers or three witches which may have
been based on the ones from Macbeth
episode 2 was title toil in trouble
making me believe they've indeed been
heading this route now around them we
see black pillars infused with gold and
this Gold's later shown to be in the
stormtrooper armor as well this is
similar to how kylo's helmet was fixed
during rise of Skywalker and this build
off the back of the Japanese technique
which is called tinsugi kinsuki and this
involves repairing broken pottery by
fusing it together with pieces of gold
to create the effect that we see it
turns out that these have been reaching
out to her and not drawn but there's a
great sense of prime fear oozing out
from Morgan smelling Jedi within Sabine
this does kind of hint that she's slowly
starting to tap into her abilities
rapping Sabine up in a red laser ring
this idea of being wrapped in red of
course could also resemble the night
sisters long short not gonna Theory time
it but I wonder if Sabine might become a
night sister herself instead of becoming
a Jedi now they may not though as the
witches refer to Sabine as an eight like
she was an object or some kind of animal
this clearly doesn't sit right with
Balin who feels like he's going back on
his word he was of course trained to be
honorable and I actually don't think
that his goals align with Morgan
you are trying to be something more now
Morgan is really pitting herself to
become a powerful entity in the Star
Wars Universe he can really start to see
how she took over the planet in the
magistrate episode and I wonder if she's
going to be a sort of evil queen figure
to stand side by side withdrawn do I
send some romance on the cards I don't
know yeah but there are a lot of things
that they can do with her I actually
think it would be quite a good twist if
they had bailing and shin turn on them
because they're not aligned with their
goals I saw a theory that baleen might
actually have came to this galaxy to
restart the Jedi Academy far away from
the eyes of the Empire which I think
would be a pretty cool idea Luke is sort
of doing the same thing and I think that
would be a really clever way to take
things touching upon Order 66 balance
clearly conflicted but he believes that
burning things down is the only way to
start again he may have even come here
to potentially destroy everything and I
have to say this is such a cool scene
between them now discussing power is
fleeting he wants a new beginning and
maybe here he can say safely start
things up again the Jedi regard the
pyridian Galaxy kind of like how we
regard the Star Wars Galaxy and see it
as just a fairy tale about a far away
Galaxy long long ago could butcher that
quote now in the establishing shot we
also see three wolves on a hill and this
mirrors the three witches we encounter
these more later on and wolves actually
have a big tie to Ezra due to his
kinship with the loath wolves alone here
he just loves wolves as well and both
skull and Harry are named after wolves
from Norse mythology now his kinship to
the Wolves could explain how he survived
for so long and it was so cool seeing
him back later on we'll talk about it
but I loved how he resembled the photo
of his dad from Rebels which was such a
cool way that I thought they took things
now back in the South Sabine tries to
tap into the force in order to escape
and it almost looks like it works
however this is actually the rumbling of
thrawn's ship and he's back baby he's
back he's got that drawn dad bod thrown
dad mod action figures available now I'm
gonna buy I mean hot toys I'm about to
give you all my money and your own ship
is known as the Chimera and the Imperial
eye class Star Destroyers appeared at
numerous times throughout the Saga and
expanded law in the nowra's Legends
continuity it first appeared in the end
of the Empire back in 1991. there we
work things so its first appearance was
in the Rebels Episode 9 Squadron before
was taken away during the Battle of
lothal just as an FYI that happened
roughly 10 years ago on the timeline so
the characters have been off in this
galaxy for roughly about a decade anyway
the Chimera had its namesaking grade on
the whole which thrawn had first seen
when he was part of the chess Academy it
overshadows the group and were
introduced to his Legion of
Stormtroopers and also his right hand
Enoch Enoch actually has a lot going on
with him beyond the cool mask and he
pulls from lots of things in terms of
Law and influence clearly riffing on
Samurai this is something Star Wars
heavily pulled from with a work of
kurosara being somehow influenced
Lucas's work the Magis an episode that
introduced us to a live action Ahsoka
also had lots of callbacks to his films
and it's clear that this is too
influenced a lot of filoni's work I feel
like the name Enoch May potentially be a
reference to the biblical character who
was Adam's great great great great
grandson and was also known as great
grandfather he lived for 365 years and
this happened before he was taken
directly to Heaven he's one of the only
people who went directly there instead
of dying which may metaphorically be him
going to another galaxy and so on I'm
pretty sure the Book of Enoch was fully
removed from the Bible due to clashing
with certain ideas and this name maina
providing a basis for things as we get
further into the show interestingly
Enoch replaces Rook who in Rebels acted
as thrawn's protector in the Legends
continuity Rook ended up killing thrawn
so they may use him for something like
that as we get further down the line now
thrawn struts in at this point with his
classic pose of holding his hands behind
his back this really speaks to his mind
and how he doesn't need to fight using
his hands or even strike up a defense
man's a genius and yeah again what a
stellar entrance those backstories
changed a number of times throughout the
continuity and like I said he was killed
by his low bodyguard guessing we're
gonna avoid all that and that they want
him to become more of a main villain for
a soccer and Co which is a big deviation
from who he fought originally that was
more around Luke in the gang but I think
they'll likely just keep things centered
on a circus group and those now with
Mando we know that Amanda movie's coming
as well and after the downfall of moff
Gideon I think thrawn will be the next
big bad that unites the side shows
anyway thrawn's always been a standout
due to his blue skin and red eyes with a
striking white uniform that makes him
stand out wherever he goes is that is
that Elon Musk now we don't know much
about his childhood but he was born on
rental and upon reaching maturity he
then joined the renter Academy
possessing an extremely strategic mind
he rose to the ranks until he became a
high-ranking member in the chiss defense
Fleet and renter actually exists outside
of the unknown regions of the Galaxy so
it's not like he isn't used to being in
Uncharted areas either way he wished to
seek out other civilizations and he
traveled into areas of space that had
him coming across Anakin Skywalker I
feel like Anakin being brought back into
the show was done for a reason as it
allows his padawans in our face against
the Ally that brought him into the
Empire now the first meeting happened
when the Jedi was still in charge but it
was at a time in which things were
changing brought before Palpatine he
ended up gaining his respect due to the
feeling that democracy was a waste of
time he wasn't impressed with how the
Republic was being run and swords
eventual collapse as being inevitable
refusing to allow the chis to join up
with him he still worked alongside the
chancellor and wants Order 66 hit that's
when he decided to integrate with the
Imperials he joined the Royal Academy on
coruscan and after gaining numerous
promotions he eventually became the
grand Admiral this made him what I
believe is the only high-ranking alien
in the organized station and I know
they're all aliens technically but you
know what I mean this actually helped
him in a lot of ways as he had a totally
different kind of tactic to the rest of
the cronies in the group whereas they
try and Stamp Out anything that was
different he on the other side tried to
understand it studying on in culture he
tried to know his enemy and this gave
him a massive Advantage when engaging
them in combat he studied the Jedi
Rebels and Mandalorian making him the
perfect file for any future films
involving all three at this point he
gained control of the seventh fleet
which was deployed to the lothal sector
to squash out the rise of rebellion
Revenge he defeated by Ezra the pair
were taken out of there by pergol and
this leads us to the point we're at now
walking in to finally greet those who've
come to save him we get a better look at
his Troopers and according to the rumors
these are actually Undead Warriors that
were resurrected by the night sisters
this is something we've seen lays
throughout the Saga and it's appeared in
things like the Clone Wars and also fall
in order during the latter you travel to
dathomir at several points in the game a
man and one Mission zombie-like
creatures are birthed out of PODS to
attack you as you try and Escape
something similar happened in the Clone
Wars where the Knight sisters conjured
the dead out these pods and I think it
actually retroactively explains what
happened with Marek I think he was the
prototype to get us used to the idea
this sort of thing could be done and
though they didn't quite explain what
was going on with him his death kinda
gave it away I am Wade the night
sister's doing this equally shows why
they're so valuable to thrawn and the
Empire's biggest problem at the moment
is racing an army during the Clone Wars
they were able to do this quickly due to
the the Clones but in the desperation
they never question and look too deeply
into what was going on with them this is
why Order 66 was able to be carried out
and clones were eventually phased out
due to the cost that came with them it's
easier to conscript soldiers but in the
end this came with its downsides in the
case of the Stormtroopers they weren't
born and bred to be soldiers and
couldn't even hit the like button if
they were watching an amazing episode
breakdown now while all this is going on
we know that moth Gideon's trying to
make his own Army of force-wielding
clones outfitted with dark trooper armor
and this is so that he can take over
things as well pulps of course does what
he does too but I think this is gonna be
thrawn's main way to take over
everything either way they look badass
and at this point thrawn recognizes
Balon due to his name thrawn says that
balen isn't the first Jedi to leave the
order and he's likely referring to both
Count Dooku and also Anakin Skywalker
drawn actually we were so smart he used
his brain to deduce that Darth Vader was
Anakin based on how Vader acted and his
past experience working with him when he
was a Jedi a thrawn ends up meeting
Sabine and Judah her freeing him from
Exile he allows her to go out searching
for Ezra now this attachment that the
Jedi forbid has led to thrawn
potentially coming back and it may Doom
anyone well well it doesn't because
we'll get the sequel trilogy but it may
cause some problems for a couple of
years now giving Sabine a wolf named
Hala he lets her know that once they
leave they're gonna be stranded forever
I think they'll use a Circa to get back
but mt's doing a big video soon to talk
about his series on it so make sure that
you stay subscribed to the channel now
she ends up having a bit of a go at
howler and after losing her family in
Ezra it seems like Sabine is some trauma
that's given her abandonment issues is
also highlights her lack of patience
which is a trait that Jedi should have
and this is why it was the first thing
that Yoda tested Lucan it's all the
trick anyway and they do want to be in a
fine Ezra and this is so that the pair
can be destroyed that that's gonna
happen mate but in a really cool moment
we get to see her pull out a tracking
device and this looks like the one that
Han used on Hearth when he was searching
for Luke attacked by Riders Sabine
bursts out a Mandalorian wires before
then grabbing the lightsaber showing how
skill she now is we also later hear the
word Bakken which is apparently a term
for a Jedi trained out in the wild
bockin is the Japanese wooden sword
which ties back to the whole Samurai
thing anyway back with thrawn we seize
the troops man up and get a really
touching moment with Sabine and howler
it also brings us across the naughty who
are proud
Lobster Lads they're kind of like ewoks
in a way and we get a sort of play on
the layer meeting Wicked scene for the
first time knowing Star Wars these are
probably gonna be probably gonna be the
people that help to destroy thrawn and
they recognize sabine's little Rebel
symbol as they also have a necklace of
it clearly belongs to Ezra but back with
bale and he further touches upon his
goals to start something more this will
be something better than the Jedi and
their orange lightsabers actually
highlight this neither fully red nor
what colors a Jedi would have they sit
in the middle trying to make something
better now we have really started
seeping the more mystical and religious
side of Star Wars with everything that's
going on I actually think that Anakin's
gonna return as a god figure at some
point and that he'll sort of become the
Star Wars equivalent of year Jesus
archetype I'll be careful how I word
that because if Jesus wasn't blowing up
planets and killing younglings to be
fair but let's look at the evidence and
and how they kind of line up so Anakin
was created through an Immaculate
Concept action and he was also seen as
being the chosen one in his death he
brought balance to the force which could
be seen as something similar to how
Jesus died for our sins I know he
doesn't exactly line up with Jesus and
across all religions there are these
types of figures so maybe Anakin is just
kind of that Jedi equivalent amusing
Jesus as my Mainframe of reference
because I was raised Christian so that's
like the main thing I have knowledge
however but I think the christ-like
figures exist in a lot of religions
myths and also Legends now Palpatine
acted as the devil and he tempted Anakin
who sadly succumbed to it due to his
love for Padme the Force ghost could
somewhat be seen as his resurrection and
he now sits on a higher plane of
existence looking overall I think Anakin
may be revealed to be a modest God which
actually has a lot of ties to the clone
wars in the series Anakin clashed with
the modus Gordon is the sun who too try
to turn him to the dark side by showing
him visions of the future this is much
like how the visions of Padme dying in
childbirth eventually led to Anakin
turning over however he redeemed himself
by destroying the emperor and I think
that he'll exist out in the world
Between Worlds as someone who guides and
shapes things much like how a guard
would last week we talked about how we
think he may replace the Sun and that
Ahsoka herself could become the daughter
after sitting on it I think that he may
become the father with Ahsoka becoming
the daughter and then Ezra becoming the
son Ahsoka already has her energies
within her as she gave up her life force
in order to resurrect her now he had the
heir to the Empire film coming up and I
think these characters will likely come
together for that at some point in order
to defeat thrawn the idea of a trinity
is not only present through our
Christianity under the religions but
it's also very present in Star Wars as
well the Morris gods were a trinity and
the Knight sister Temple also had three
figures too the star map was opened up
by making a triquetra which too is
linked directly with the Trinity lastly
we also have the ancient god figures on
Zephyr which I think may be from this
alternate Galaxy so I think that this
series and the movies that to follow
will very much be about building a new
Trinity for The Saga now it could be
Anakin as the father and Lucan Lair as a
son and daughter but it just depends
what direction they want to take stuff
should have probably few times this
whole thing but we'll close out this
time you don't know you idiots
anyway we see some Bandits on the top of
a hill which clearly evokes imagery from
an old western movie gonna be a naughty
little Alliance and we see elsewhere as
they lead Sabine into their culture
again it's like Leia on how she was
integrated into the Ewoks after offering
them something like Sabine did with the
little naughty guy now if you want to
support the channel we're still selling
arasaka and gragoons by t-shirt that
pulls a quote directly from their first
meeting all the money goes towards
helping videos like this get made and
we've got a ton of merch now available
on the store impress your loved ones
with coming out with nonsense while
wearing a theory time shirt let your
girl know that size Matters without
Ant-Man one it's all on there right now
and thank you everyone that's picked up
one now we finally see Ezra reunite with
Sabine
we almost cried I wasn't crying yet dust
was in the room but it was such a cool
reunion and him acting as a naughty
protector explains how they survived
kinda see him as a sort of Obi-Wan
figure as well who's been living off the
Wilderness and helping where he can I
throw on talks to the mothers and they
bring up the threat of Fate this could
be a reference to the sisters of Fate
from Greek mythology who used to hold
threads as lifelines and then cut them
to kill people learning that Ahsoka is
coming thrawn feels betrayed by Balin
and they slowly start to prepare for her
arrival next week now he wants to know
everything about her and this fits him
with his ammo of learning about his
opponents as for next time I think we
already know what's gonna happen and
this is due to what's being said here
and there and how episode 5 ended I
think we're gonna see thrawn attack
Ahsoka then head out back home I think
she'll be the one that saves Ezra and
Sabine as for thrown in his attack
though those republic ships were left
sitting above saito's which I think
thrawn's gonna show up and make an
example of next time even on the Chimera
is an operating Apple power I think
we're gonna see how Next Level he is
when he easy wipes them out as we
mentioned thrawn is a genius when it
comes to strategy and he should make
short work of them upon getting back and
that wraps up the episode and as for
next time we have a couple of weeks here
and there that kind of Point towards
where things will be going drop out the
video obviously if you don't want to
know but huge thank you for sticking it
out with me now according to the leaks
next time we'll see Anakin back in some
form or another with him apparently
appearing in both that episode and also
the finale who also have rumors that
thrawn's gonna win and eventually come
out Victorious at the end of the season
being described as the Disney shows
version of The Empire Strikes Back it's
been said that in order to set up his
Trilogy they need to set him up as a
threat and have him come out on top
whether that means a character is gonna
die or fall to the dark side we'll have
to see but yeah that's apparently where
we're going to be heading towards the
end of the show anyway huge thank you
for joining us yet again I know some of
you are watching this late into the
night you can probably hear from my
voice I'm not 100 at the moment but uh
yeah thanks for sticking with me
appreciate it hopefully next week I've
not got a cold but yeah thank you for
rocking with me and I really appreciate
your support now if you want to join the
channel as a member please click the
join button and as a thank you'll get
earlier access to videos every week but
just 99 Cents and 99 Pence a month you
know it's cheaper than a magnet my
slowly used to be in the 90s you can
help support us and get early videos as
a thank you so yeah if you're inclined
that way we'd massively appreciate it
now if you want something else to watch
you've got a video on screen right now
so definitely head over there right
after this now huge thank you again a
surf shark for sponsoring the video and
if you want something else to watch then
click the one on screen right now in
which empty goes over all all those
lessons that Anakin was trying to teach
a soccer it's really well thought out
got lots of positive comments on it so
definitely head over there right after
this by the way thank you for sticking
through the video I've been poor I'll
see you next time take care peace